(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Rising out of the forest
in what was once a
wasteland is a masterpiece
that has taken
decades to build.
And the guy behind it says
he's not finished yet.
- [Narrator] Peilun is
building this valley
as a tribute to the ancient
civilization that once lived here.
It covers nearly 50 acres,
and most of it has been built by hand.
- [Narrator] It was
thought that these masks
had the power to help
people overcome hardships
and ward off diseases.
While Peilun decides the
design of every structure,
it's these locals who
really know the stonework.
- [Narrator] This place wasn't built
only with a tribute in mind.
An artist himself, Peilun
wanted others to be inspired
by his work, and form a community.
(upbeat music)
(electronic music)